yeah so I like to talk to you guys a
little bit about
project I've been working on - well how
help people maybe write more easily on
their computer so just to give you an
idea of what I'll be covering I'd like
to first introduce a problem of digital
writing and talk about some relevant
technology that already exists I'll talk
I'll talk a little bit about my own
experience developing a solution and
I'll show you a little bit of what I
built there are a couple reasons why you
might be interested so first of all I'll
be talking about technology I understand
this is a technology at a colloquium so
hopefully some of that will be
interesting I'd also like to share my
experience with entrepreneurship it's
something is kind of hard to get a grasp
of how it works without hearing a bunch
of examples so maybe I can offer one of
those examples to you
and then lastly since this is generally
a pretty technical crowd maybe some of
you are still looking for better ways to
draw on your computer so maybe I can
help give you a help you make a more
well-informed decision just a little bit
about myself I just finished my PhD in
mathematics at Princeton I was studying
partial differential equations and
general relativity I consider myself a
computer enthusiast
probably as many of you guys as well and
I've had a couple technical jobs a
number of hobby projects along the way
but as a disclaimer I don't necessarily
consider myself to be an industry expert
in computer science yeah yeah I'm John
stokin and I also wanted to in the
beginning thank Andy and Dennis for
inviting me to come speak yeah okay all
right so I thought I would start with a
quote by Steve Wozniak I had a TV set
and a typewriter and that made me think
a computer should be laid out like a
typewriter and a video screen
okay so
I thought for a little bit you know what
are the the ways that a computer has
helped us go beyond the typewriter how
how does it really improve our process
of typing right and I sort of split it
into four categories so the first which
is to me the most important is the you
have the freedom to change what you
wrote right once it's down on paper if
you're typing then it's sort of stuck
there
but with computers you can delete cut
copy and paste you can really iterate
with your ideas and just you know put
the right ideas down and work with them
the computer also allows instant
communication so you have email chat etc
live document sharing like Google Docs
it also helps with storage an
organization and it can provide some
form of intelligence like spellcheck but
there are lots of ideas that we have
which are not easy to to use a
typewriter or a computer to express and
so then we might ask the question is a
computer better than pen and paper for
expressing those ideas and if we look at
the same four categories that I
discussed with the computer there are
actually a lot of analogous advantages
to being able to use a computer for
these so in terms of changing what you
write if you're trying to solve a
difficult problem you don't want your
first question to be where on the page
should I start writing this equation
right you just want to you want to you
want to get the ideas down and then work
with them additionally for doing
calculations you often end up rewriting
the same things over and over right so
if you're going from this line to this
line you know maybe you just move a
couple terms around two terms cancel or
something so that's a new advantage for
communication something may be similar
to Google Docs but for handwriting
storage and organizations more or less
the same intelligence I think is one of
the more interesting things we we still
don't see much of this but there's a
potential to check for errors and
calculations just like spellcheck
and then also even to perform
calculations based on things that we
write but I leave a a question mark up
there because for some reason most
people seem to still just be comfortable
using pen and paper they're not really
using computers for this and so this is
the way that I like to phrase the
problem of digital writing that we don't
use typewriters anymore but we still use
pen and paper ok so here's another quote
by this time by Steve Jobs God gave us
10 styluses let's not invent another so
as you may guess he's referring to
capacitive touch in this case right so
this I first because this is probably
the most well known technology for input
on to a computer besides say a mouse and
a keyboard and definitely if if one were
to think of drawing on a tablet which
seems more natural for these types of
ideas then a capacitive touch might be
the place to start just just a little
bit of background in capacitive touch so
it uses a 2-dimensional array of tiny
capacitors on the screen the presence of
a finger affects the mutual capacitance
and and this is something that then can
be measured and converted into some
coordinates interestingly enough it can
detect multiple fingers at the same time
it's made popular by the iPhone in 2007
and it's very well known there are a
couple reasons why it's not very good
for drawing though so most obviously it
usually requires a blunt object on the
screen so you can't write precisely
there's actually an exception to this
you can get some battery-powered
styluses I actually have a much finer
tip but I'll get into by those also
don't work very well it another problem
you have is confusing the palm of the
screen and then it has a relatively long
measurement time the amount of time it
takes to actually figure out the
position of something is actually too
long
in contrast there's another piece of
technology the inductive stylus which is
really quite fantastic for writing and
I'm seeing some people nodding their
heads here which is it is great to hear
because I've actually learned that most
people still are not familiar with this
technology but I'd like to tell a little
bit about how this works so what happens
is you need a special board behind the
screen that emits the localized
electromagnetic wave and then you have a
special stylus that with a circuit tuned
to that wave that will reflect it back
if it's at the right frequency and so
then the so the board emits a localized
wave and then it switches to try to
detect the reflection and that will
allow the board to figure out the
proximity of the stylus so this is used
in only a few well-known tablets so the
Microsoft Surface pro the Apple iPad pro
with the Apple pencil that's what that
that's all about and then I have a
Samsung device here that has an S Pen so
the S Pen also uses that technology and
as I will now show you this is a lot
better for writing detailed expressions
but I would like to actually go over the
patent a little bit more this is a
patent by Wacom just explaining how it
works again so here they have an array
of coils going from left to right the
the hot the the height in this diagram
is actually the the full height of the
screen and then they're about say 40 or
so coils going from left to right along
the screen they're overlapping and each
individual coil you can select one send
an alternating current through it that
will emit the electromagnetic wave then
you stop sending the alternate you stop
sending the current and then that same
coil can function as a detector and then
if the stylus is nearby it reflects it
back something that I think is quite
remarkable about this idea is you can
have these you you can have a
non-trivial circuit inside the stylus
and that allows you to say press a
button on the side of the stylus or
detect the
that the the stylus is pressing on the
screen so even without having any
battery in the stylus you can have this
this functional input okay so going over
the measurement and response so in this
figure here we have some clock signal a
and then B is a signal that determines
whether we're emitting or detecting a
response so you say take a and B and
then you get C D would be the resonance
in the stylus itself so as you're
sending the signal then the stylus
becomes more resonant and then as you
stop sending the signal then the the
stylus will will emit less back and then
e is measured response from the stylus
and then from there is basically
processing signal E but E is basically
what you're trying to measure and that
will give you an idea the proximity of
the stylus to the board or to the
individual coil and then you do this for
a bunch of different coils so you repeat
it a bunch of times and then you can
plot the response over all the coils and
then do some statistics on that and you
can determine approximately where the
the stylus is looking actually I
shouldn't say approximately it's it's
incredibly precise and in this patent
they they say that it can take them
about 10 milliseconds and that is fast
enough to make a pretty precise to
precisely measure where the stylus has
been okay so just to make things a
little clearer again so when you have
capacitive touch you have the the
measuring device is transparent and on
top of the screen for the inductive
stylists you have the measuring device
located behind the screen okay so some
drawbacks to the stylus or to this
inductive stylus technology is that well
you have to have a special stylus and
you have to have a special detecting
board which must be placed underneath
the screen in the tablet and this I
think is one of the main you know
challenges to getting this technology
widely adopted
if you already got a tablet or you
already have your favorite computer then
either you already have this or you
don't really have a hope of using this
behind your screen it also has a
drawback of being a little bit sensitive
to noise so for some products like the
Microsoft Surface and the Apple pencil
they actually have to have some power in
the stylus itself so they can't just
rely on unmitigated kn'l for other
devices that don't like the Samsung
tablet you notice for example the camera
is not in the location of the screen for
that same kind of reason so some of the
devices will interfere with this
measuring technique but the benefits are
that you have you have a stylus with
multiple buttons you don't have palm
rejection issues anymore because your
palm doesn't interfere with a signal and
you have very fast measurement time okay
so I'm not going to go through all the
technologies out there but there are a
number of creative technologies I didn't
want to say that this was exhaustive
probably one of my favorites is is the
smart pen that uses the de bruyne
pattern so this is a pattern that if you
look at some piece of the pattern it
it's so it's it's it's a long sequence
such that if you know a very small part
of the sequence then you know exactly
where you are on the sequence right and
so so someone had a clever idea of
putting all these dots on a piece of
paper and then you have a pen with a
camera that looks and then it can just
see a couple dots and you're where the
pen is and then it can tell where the
pen is on the paper okay so here is a
quick comparison of that the main
technologies that I just mentioned so
this is using a blunt stylus on a
standard capacitive device okay I have
the same person writing each of these so
this is using a battery-powered stylus
also with a capacitive touch device so
if I jump back and forth between the two
a couple times you can see that it's
possible to write a little bit more
cisely but unfortunately it's still
pretty hard to tell what the person was
even writing okay because they're
writing too fast
in contrast this is what you get if you
use an inductive stylist so it's should
be a lot clearer to in fact maybe even
hard to tell that this was written on a
computer instead of pencil and paper pen
and paper unless of course you read it
in which case you know that is using an
inductive house okay so the conclusion
from this part of the talk is that there
is some great technology out there to
help people draw personally I found this
incredibly useful when I was in college
I took all of my notes and did all of my
homework on an inductive tablet it was
that good and I basically never had to
use paper and I've thought it was quite
unfortunate when I saw that most people
didn't have access to this technology so
yes so that here's the conclusion I
would say that a computer is definitely
more useful than pen and paper if you
have this technology okay and then I
couldn't find exactly a quote on this
particular technology but I found a
quote so Albert Einstein said I admire
the elegance of your method of
computation must be nice to ride through
these field fields upon the course of
two mathematics while the likes of us
have to make our way laboratory on foot
so the context here who's talking to
love each IV des about tensor calculus
but I think if you completely take it
out of context then it makes for a great
quote for for the inductive writing
technology okay so now I'd like to
switch gears a little bit and tell you
about some of my experience developing
or trying working on developing a
solution to help more people get their
ideas onto their computers okay
so again a little bit of a personal
story I first was exposed to this
inductive writing technology in high
school they had a cart of these tablets
that they would bring into math class
and then we could all right on them I
thought it was very useful so I
one for college and then a little bit
after college I bought this MacBook Air
but really missed having the accesses
technology and thought well wouldn't it
be great if there was some sort of
peripheral device that I could just have
to sort of complement my laptop so I
couldn't find one for a while I
eventually got an iPad because they were
pretty cool and decided to buy like the
stylus with the best reviews online and
thought you know maybe this will do the
job it was it was quite disappointing
though so then I started thinking okay
well how could how difficult would it be
to make one of these things so the first
idea that I had was all right let's try
coming up how how inexpensive could you
get an inductive writing tablet to be
maybe you strip out all the fancy things
maybe it can't even say like give you a
good web browser or something but what
if it's just good enough for doing the
drawing right that could help with costs
and then maybe you could even come up
with a revenue model to help you know
maybe you don't make money off of the
device itself but you can still run a
sustained business by helping people
help each other right so you have some
sort of tutoring model or something
where are some student is working on a
homework problem they get stuck and they
press a button and then someone else can
sort of interact with them remotely I
thought this would be great it has the
advantage of helping students and some
low-income neighborhoods and
hard-to-reach areas and then also it can
help minimize distraction because people
now when they're doing their homework if
they have the internet around and stuff
it's it can be a bit distracting so it
seemed it seemed like definitely a
really fun idea to play around with so I
started trying to build one so there's a
Raspberry Pi inexpensive computer and
then this is the guts of one of these
this is one of these inductive boards so
Wacom sells these boards that don't have
a screen that you can plug in as a
peripheral device and it's it's very
frustrating not to be able to see what
you're drawing when you're drawing on it
but it's
very good for if you want to get access
to this technology without spending much
money and as I said earlier this
technology works through the screen so
you have the the detecting board
underneath the screen so you in theory
can take this board and then just put an
ordinary LCD screen on top and so that
that actually worked so okay so I wrote
some software for it as well basically
you should try to take away everything
that could be you know using up
processing power so you can focus on the
writing and so here's a little video
example of the of the tablet in action
so here I'm squaring an expression and
I'm it's a lot faster say to copy that
expression than to rewrite it twice
here's another little video and so
showing the ability to say add more
space at the end of the page and then
here's one final video showing how you
can take say some ideas that you had
drawn maybe very quickly and then
rearranging them and we imagine them the
way they should be presented on a page
okay but I quickly learned that one of
the so there's a lot of problems with
this idea that I had the first of which
and I had no idea when I got started but
building the tablet is actually not the
hard part so when you're trying to to
find a solution that is economically
viable there are a lot of factors that
go into this besides actually just being
able to create the solution yourself and
and then another slightly related issue
is that I knew basically no high school
students so the the initial plan that I
had I basically would have would have
had almost no way to actually go about
implementing it even if say I could have
access to a bunch of these tablets so I
had I was very fortunate to eventually
get to participate
one of these ideation accelerator
programs my wife at the time was grad
student at Penn State and they had a
community program for a couple people
who wanted to commercialize an idea and
they took me into it and gave me some
good advice and basically encouraged me
to abandon Hardware completely and told
me to talk to a lot of people
so actually abandoning hardware was I
was really really against this because
the way I was thinking is you know this
inductive technology is great we just
need to get more people to use it right
and there's no way software is going to
I mean doesn't seem like there are many
good ways that software alone could help
us solve this problem it really felt
like a hardware problem but the the step
of talking to people was really really
key and and I'll get into that now but
it was something that I certainly was
not interested in doing because I like
to you know sit at home and work on my
own little problems but it's daunting
but it's definitely rewarding so and
again a part of this talk is is aimed
towards if you at some point in in your
future decide that you want to solve a
problem that other people face so here's
some practical advice for for how to go
about doing that so you can tell for
mistakes that I made when I started
talking to people because they're the
four things I said that you should not
do so the first is hand people a paper
survey the second is to assume that you
just want to convince investors that
your idea is a cool one it almost seems
like that's always what you want to do
but that's not the main reason I would
say what you really want to do is you
want to have a conversation with people
and it's very interesting I found that
if you want to learn how someone is
doing something currently they're often
willing to have a lengthy conversation
with you like even 30 minutes and it
seemed very odd to me that
that you know strangers would be willing
to talk to you for over half an hour
about something but this is really the
way that you learn how people are
currently struggling with their problems
and and sometimes it it helped you have
to guide the conversation a little bit
but after talking to a couple people you
start getting better at keeping the
conversation it in line with helping you
understand their challenges okay
also I'd recommend this I if you go to
talking to humans calm there's a great
little PDF fun with a lot of practical
advice okay so here are some of the
things that I some of the patterns I
noticed when I was trying to talk to
people so a lot of researchers we talked
to say they use Skype and hold up equate
hold up say they'll draw something on
either the chalkboard or a piece of
paper and hold it up so the other person
can look at it a lot of people also
complained about having to type long
expressions in order to get their
equation and especially something like
this which it definitely seems
complicated but if you actually want to
type that equation up it's very
complicated right and if you're missing
a parenthesis somewhere in that
expression then who knows how long it'll
take you to find that you know where
that missing presence was right
definitely distracting when it would be
so much quicker to draw it on paper
sorry yeah so I mean I'm sure they're
aware of this problem too but I mean
this is generally what people have to do
right they have to type these actually
some of my favorite complaints were and
from multiple people talking about how
they would be using some educational
software and typing in a chat window to
the other person typing in the equation
and then on the other side it comes out
with some emoticon or something so
yeah actually that's something I wish I
understood a bit more but I've I've
talked to people in the US who do
foreign language stuff mainly
universities oh you should talk to
Richard oh yeah I mean it's really
interesting how like you you can talk to
people and you start learning the the
challenges that they're dealing with
I definitely would encourage it
especially if you you know want to I
mean it's very easy to look at some you
know successful idea or some successful
implementation of an idea and think that
this person either they were there at
the right place at the right time or it
was you know Billy they just figured out
the way to do it but I imagine now
whenever I look at these cases that
there was probably a lot of a lot of
this kind of process that that you
usually don't hear about okay so besides
those observations there were a couple
other observations that I started to
make the first is that universities do
spend money on software so going back to
my original idea was to look at like try
to help high school students and you
know presumably parents of high school
students would would be the paying
customers here is like a group of people
that I know a little bit more right and
understand a little bit more and then
but probably the most surprising thing
to me was I 80 to 90% of the people I
talked to were not even aware that this
inductive technology exists and this
room may not be the best sample because
we'll were in the computer science
building but it was surprising how how
many people really just thought that
drawing on a tablet was like drawing
with capacitive touch and it was just
awful which by the way gives me hope
that you know maybe someday this
technology will be a lot more widespread
and maybe we'll move beyond this problem
but it hasn't happened yet
okay so here's sort of the the new plan
that I had after I talked to a bunch of
people I'm gonna focus on academics and
universities because I actually know
these people my goal now is to help
researchers communicate their technical
ideas over a distance so the classic
examples being say to researchers at two
universities who are collaborating on a
paper or maybe a grad student who is
advisor as you know off giving a talk
somewhere but they need to discuss some
something that the grad students working
on and then because most people aren't
aware of this hardware try to find the
most affordable solutions and equip
departments with this technology so that
they can have effective communication
all right and then in 2016 there was
this new program that Princeton started
called the Tiger challenge the idea was
to help help teach students how to come
up with creative new ideas by again
talking to a lot of people and
understanding their challenges so I
proposed this problem find a way to make
digital writing less cumbersome without
needing an expensive tablet and there
are a couple of students who spent more
of this time trying to identify what are
the real challenges we have and our main
conclusions after this project was we
decided there were three main components
that go into the challenge of digital
writing there's first of all space
actually the the site the second and
third are kind of obvious so hint you
you want to have a natural feel when
you're drawing and you don't want to
spend a lot of money okay so that seemed
pretty clear we weren't quite aware as
much of the the space issue so a lot of
people expressed a desire to be able to
see a lot of what they're drawing at the
same time which makes sense especially
if you're trying to solve a complicated
problem and it takes you know pieces
from different areas you what you'd like
to be able to see all of that and they
again we noticed that a lot of people
were holding things up to a Skype camera
and so this is what got us thinking that
maybe
an interesting feature would be to take
a picture when someone's holding their
equations up or their drawings up to a
camera and then process those drawings
and convert them into some sort of
digital object
so here's well okay so this is a first
picture from what I've been building but
the eye here's the idea you you have
some drawings that you've that are on a
sheet of paper and then those drawings
themselves get processed onto some sort
of board and then each individual
component so like this equal sign is
really two different digital pieces at
this point they're there now these
digital objects that some of them in a
group can be selected and rearranged so
they're not they're no longer stuck the
way they were on on paper so this almost
sounds like a really obvious solution I
tried to think briefly like what was
preventing what was preventing this this
from me from thinking of this earlier
and and I think one of the couple of the
reasons is that recognition although
it's fantastic and I'm sure that in in
computer science department here a lot
of people get very excited about this as
a user if you're not if you have some
special set of symbols or characters and
you're trying to recognize it then it
can be actually a quite frustrating
experience to have say you're special
symbol being recognized as some other
symbol and then I also think I was kind
of I was not interested in camera base
approaches because I thought that you
know you still have to draw on paper and
so you're still sort of stuck but this
actually seems to help a lot especially
if one person say has the the writing
tablet and they're just trying to get
their colleagues somewhere else to to
enter you know some ideas than this this
actually could could help quite a bit
okay so here was the new the new idea so
it's very similar to the previous plan
that I had the main difference is that
now we're talking about something that
is designed to help people even if they
don't have one of these special tablets
so assuming they have some sort of
camera or something which most people
have their phones or a laptop with a
webcam and so again in the ideal setup
if you care a lot about space and you
have a tablet then your computer screen
is probably most often the the largest
viewing space that you have so you can
you can be showing all of your drawings
up there but then say drawing on a
portion of it with your tablet and
that's something I can probably
demonstrate at the end but then there's
also the scan feature so if say your
colleague doesn't have one of these
tablets they can still be inputting
valuable information okay so basically
since that since we came up with that
idea I spent most of last fall in winter
actually building the Minimum Viable
Product which I think was was actually
very productive I mean this is sort of
getting on a little bit of a tangent but
again for any of you who are thinking of
building something it's amazing how much
faster you can go when the whole idea is
in your mind instead of amongst a couple
of different people so I mean teamwork
is definitely very important at some
point but it's I would looking back I
always wanted to form a team right away
but I think this was actually a very
useful period of time to be able to work
on it on my own so that was the fall in
winter I also had to write a thesis and
defend so that happened in the spring
and then during the summer I finally did
get a team together which I was very
excited about and that brings us to the
fall so now we're working on ironing out
some of the wrinkles and hopefully
having a useful tool soon so okay I
wanted to show a couple more screenshots
of what we've been building so this is
where we left off last time
it also supports some video calls so
this was something a lot of people
wanted was to be able to see the face of
the person but most of the conversation
is happening around some ideas that are
on the board
so and then also annotating PDF
documents so often if you're working on
a draft of the paper or going over say a
concept that's in a say a book where you
have the the PDF then this allows you to
do those annotations and in this example
some of these things were drawn using a
mouse
so like highlighting and the the red but
those calculations on the right were
things that were scanned in and then of
course some of the things that I imagine
would excite people in this audience
there's well okay so if you like typing
and latex then you can type latex
equations as well and we're just getting
started on the recognition and
calculation the calculation features not
on the live beta app right now but some
of the recognition is okay so basically
we've changed a little bit in our vision
we're hoping to be sort of a
next-generation drawing tool that
includes these features like the webcam
scan but also handwrite handwriting
recognition which again to get back to
the frustration of writing things we
imagine sort of building these packages
that allow you to specify say if you're
in a particular research subfield maybe
you can specify like what kinds of
symbols belong in that package and even
how to calculate with them so that's
sort of how we would imagine these being
implemented in practice we are working
to support modern browsers and tablets
and again our goal is to help students
organize and show their notes with each
other and also to help researchers
communicate over a distance and yes our
URL is scratch our tool comm if you want
to play around with that at some point
just to give you an idea what's on my
mind right now
so we have a couple a couple of
immediate concerns are managing
persistent data so we're just about
settling on a file format and the reason
it's such an immediate concern is
because once we start storing people's
data it becomes a lot more challenging
if you want to change something later
then you have to go through and update
all of that or have some sort of
backwards compatibility our user
interface it still can use some work as
you may discover if you want to give it
a try I think we're getting there though
and our tablet apps are a little bit
behind the the web app in development
but they're also making progress yeah
and and what I would really love to do
someday if this actually starts becoming
useful for a lot of people is as maybe
returning back to that first vision of
helping a lot of people in in different
areas get the especially students get
the help that they need but yes I wanna
caution that we have a long way to go so
I'm certainly not claiming to be doing
that anytime soon okay so maybe I'll
conclude my talk in a moment and I can
give a couple of demos actually why
don't I give a quick demo now okay so
okay so here is the app and I have on
this sheet of paper I have a diagram
with a mistake on it so I'm going to
take a picture of this diagram and
select it
so here here are my digital the the
diagram sort of digitized right so now
I'm free to say take an eraser and erase
the part that I didn't want and then say
select this move it down over here okay
so there's a little bit of a
demonstration a lot easier I think to
draw this first on paper and then and
then digitize it instead of trying to do
that right away unless of course you
have a drawing tablet so I'll log in
then click this synchronize button here
now I have also a duplicate drawing
screen on here and now I can say I don't
know circle by one or do some sort of
calculations so I'll do the cosine theta
plus sine theta squared I love this
calculation just because it becomes
quite clear that when you do these
calculations you have to rewrite things
over and over again and trigonometric
functions there's a lot of writing
involved right so I can select this term
and make some copies and and then okay
so cosine squared theta plus two cosine
theta sine theta plus sine squared theta
and then I of course would like to
rearrange these terms right so I can
group these terms together because
there's this nice trigonometric identity
right so then this is equal to one plus
two cosine theta sine theta
you can also add as I said you can add
these blank pages right so and then say
select things and rearrange them the way
you want all right so that's hopefully a
little bit of a demonstration of the
ability to sort of more freely work with
your drawings yeah so so I guess the
main things I hope you might take away
from my talk are that computers can also
be very helpful for drawing ideas as
well besides just typing them not all
tablets are the same so I I see at least
someone in the audience who has a tablet
that looks like it has an inductive
writing scientist so that's good but if
you are ever thinking of getting one I
would encourage you to look for the
Microsoft Surface pro the Apple iPad pro
with the pencil or the Samsung tablet so
the the Samsung tablet as long as it has
the s-pen that's the key so you can buy
basically an identical tablet for a
little bit less that doesn't have the
s-pen and at least for this particular
purpose it's worthless
but this one is only $350 right now the
screen size is not so bad
and so I it's my it's my personal
preference regarding entrepreneurship I
definitely encourage you if you haven't
tried it before it's very it's very
interesting and rewarding experience
even if it you know doesn't go anywhere
but if you're a techie like me then you
know don't expect that the hard problem
is to actually build the thing there's a
lot of work involved in talking to
people and understanding what the real
what the real challenge is and then
lastly I hope you now know a little bit
about what I've been working on and feel
free to play around with it and sign up
for our beta thank
[Applause]
questions private because you've had
something in your head with marvellous
and you want to talk to somebody and
they look at you and you realize they
didn't we're reflecting marvelous back
yeah so well yeah no there okay so there
are a couple parts oh so what one thing
is one that so say you if you go back to
this original tablet device that I built
this was mainly I mean of course it
wasn't it was obvious that it's not
something that someone would actually
take into a class in use because this is
a big clunky thing right so part of part
of talking to people is just learning
and is learning that there are some
things that you take for granted I took
for granted that everybody knew about
this technology when it turns out that
wasn't what they knew but you're
probably also asking about now that I'm
building something like this what is it
like and getting feedback from people
and that I mean we're just starting to
get feedback I would first of all say
that some people have use it and have
told me about their them actually using
it to solve their problem and and that's
an incredibly rewarding experience to
hear about say a grad student who is
working with his friend in in the UK and
they were annotating like seven
different papers at the same time it's
very rewarding to hear that but the real
useful information that you get is
generally about the mistakes or why
isn't it you know working as well as you
would help and so it's I must say it's
it's a it's a bit of a daunting task
especially to here to get the criticisms
and then actually be able to convert
that into you know improving the product
so we definitely have a longer list than
what we've been able to get to so far
but
and and also some of the feedback that
you get is maybe not necessarily
something that you can even do because
you have to think I mean if say you're
you're designing a chair you know
someone might say oh I'd really like it
to come with a table or something right
and you have to sort of decide you know
which things are actually going to work
on yeah so yeah that's that's a very
good question so so there are a couple
ways and this is still work in progress
but for example you can select this
image and then download it as like a PNG
right
so if it's an image if say it's just
something that you wanted to put into a
document then you can do that in the
live site right now this feature isn't
supported but the whole purpose for me
adding this page is that you can also
convert that whole page into a PDF or
print that as well and if you upload PDF
documents to annotate then you can
download or print the resulting
documents with the annotations on them
it's right now it's not available on the
live site because there are a couple new
elements that we've added that aren't
that don't support that yet but we will
have that up soon yeah when you do
collaboration do you have two people
connected to the same document at the
same time or yeah so this is sort of
like a Google Docs model so it's right
now it's basically anybody who goes to
the link will be able to view and
actually this is a very good question so
one one reason why it's so helps so much
more helpful than say using Skype and
showing showing the other person what
you drew on the paper is that if say I
scan this diagram in and you are also
looking at the yeah well with Skype yeah
you can't change it but with with
something like this then you can
so I can enter my equation and then you
can say delete a term that doesn't
belong there's like two cursors
appearing on the screen at the same time
or yeah okay so it's not like you have
to commit or something no no it's it's
it's it's very much designed to be a
live process can that work how does that
scale I mean can you have more than two
people or do you have to go to a
one-to-many yeah that's so that's
something that I mean I'm sure that I
would guess probably around six or seven
people you it'll probably start having
problems so with with the current
implementation of it we have to do a
little bit more research and decide who
we're going to target so for example if
if we want to go into online classrooms
then we definitely want to be able to
support like one too many interactions
if we want to support classrooms where
say multiple people can be presenting to
each other than we have a many-to-many
issue if if we're really just looking to
sort of help like small numbers of
people then you know maybe we don't care
too much about say that's apology of the
or network but yeah we will have to
think about that somewhere in the future
yeah this isn't really appropriate or
really the real world but you might be
of use there was an episode of The Big
Bang Theory six to eight years ago where
the gang did something that sort of
touches on this we need to solve system
differential equations write them out
longhand take a photograph your
smartphone run that through an image
recognizer character recognizer submit
to an online solver engine and an email
yeah
well that's hopefully it won't be as
involved as that but yeah it's it's kind
of it's kind of interesting that we have
a nice I don't think we've really gotten
to that point yet
and by we sorry they're doing a lot of
cursory I mean their languages require
shares of assistance and they work on it
in the through the 90s because they ask
serious problems with several billion
people yeah we've heard also with
chemistry for example there's a lot of
interest in having being able to sorry
we're not using a system I'm just saying
that there's a lot of interest in being
able to take chemical molecules and say
[Music]
really derive chemical language
yeah I've never roll trying to service
organic chemists about yeah we just
started looking at some of the papers
they've been I mean you know a lot of
this a lot of what we're working on
isn't necessarily like you know
cutting-edge research into you know I
would love to spend you know most of my
time just like trying to write a cool
equation recognizer or something I mean
it seems like a very fun problem but
it's for us right now it's a matter of
priorities and I would say that we'll be
successful if we can take other you know
say if it's a system that's built on
Linux like you said or UNIX yeah so if
we can take some system like that and
make it a lot easier for a lot of people
to use I think that would be probably
our main right thesis as opposed to
right thesis yada yada yada
how did that conversation with your
adviser go yeah that's that's a good
that's a good question so well basically
I had most of my I had solved the the
the final problem for my thesis was
basically solved before the beginning of
my final year in school so I knew that I
had some time to say play around with a
project like this and that I knew at
some point I'd actually have to write
everything but if I had worked out
pretty much all the details then
hopefully the writing itself I could
have a rough guess as to how long that
would take
so it was it was a lot of writing for
about a month it ended up being about
550 pages long but and of course a very
it was very nice to you know be able to
wrap that up but yeah I'd certainly
didn't put put that off necessarily
to get enough done early enough so I
could focus on this project for a little
while sorry I don't know if any of that
really made it into my solution to the
problem it was all I'd feel kind of bad
saying this pencil and paper because I
would have liked to use this but this
wasn't ready yet
hoping to have enough of it done so that
I could actually like show my advisor
and use it but sadly I didn't quite
reach that point yeah any comments about
the possibility of incorporating 3d
constructs good 3d constructs well my
initial thought yeah so my initial
thought is I'd have to learn a little
bit more like what kinds of use this
would this would have and how many
people would want to use something like
that there's always a temptation to sort
of add all these different features but
first you have to think if you're going
to add something new you know what is
the how many people are going to benefit
from it do could you let me do my
imagine like a three-dimensional plot or
problems those are when you're actually
crunching it out working with visualize
that 3d okay often you will extract from
that a projection which goes ah sure so
yeah an image that could go in here yeah
I mean that I think would be interesting
would definitely be interesting to
include we didn't have to spend more
time thinking about
no really I mean Ivan sub Maloney to
this PhD thesis was the original sketch
pad he kept it the 2d nesting table he
did not have trends of doing very much
in the way of 3d recognizing save you
know there this is related to some
problems that I had when when I was
first building the I didn't get into a
lot of the algorithm behind actually you
know filtering the image because
probably wouldn't be incredibly
interesting to you can imagine there's
just some fresh holding involved but but
you do have these sort of you have you
you have to deal with shadows right and
so you can imagine some contrived
examples where you have something that's
really dark up here but then maybe it
gets lighter and so like if you if you
want some sort of globally consistent
drawing then then you have exactly this
Astro type problem where you know it
really looks like up here it should be
inked but down here it shouldn't be but
yeah so so those issues are even
encountered in the two-dimensional
representation my name is try and
challenge myself doing multi dimensions
why didn't I push your 2d I say yeah
take mathematics that's way too low so
you should be able to reuse some insight
like different coordinates well okay so
you know what the transformation between
courses
that's complicated so there's a
representation on math but you might
help that yeah I I mean it's at the end
of the day now since I'm trying to you
know find something that will be useful
for some select group of people I have
to figure out like you know how you know
what are the typical use cases that we
imagine for something like this and then
the question would be like does
something like 3d or I don't know higher
dimensional Cartesian it's use because
it's simple enough so you can write down
simple equations
this is multiplications rotations this
is an example there's a lot of
discussion there I'm just sure yeah
change the complete drift there are ways
of doing it yeah maybe you could tell me
a little bit more but yeah again I think
I think the the the the problem is you
know there may I mean there are ways to
do pretty much anything right but then I
don't know I mean we can't necessarily
have pretty much every feature in and
say this you know this particular
product so we have to think carefully
about you know what are the things that
most people are going to be looking for
if you add too many bells and whistles
then you know people can start getting
confused about how to use the two are so
disjoint you can't you don't seem to be
and actually getting something that
counts for a lot and it's easy for us to
think of things that you could do I mean
like when you see an opportunity to say
you some advanced mathematics or add
some really cool feature it's definitely
like that's the thing that you want to
jump into doing but I'm sort of learning
just by you know doing and doing this
long enough now I'm starting to see that
you know you have to leave some things
on the back burner yeah and I wouldn't
necessarily exclude us you know I
sometimes worried that maybe we've
already put too much in when you use
this with Skype use this is kinda client
world this currently does not interact
with Skype there's we have some it's
it's not perfectly working yet but we do
have embedded voice and video calling
that uses WebRTC if any of you are
familiar with that API from Google and
Mozilla so currently it's sort of a
standalone tool but you're certainly not
the only person who has mentioned the
idea of integrating it with Skype so
that means that I have to even if the
full interaction is only available if
they both have your client you should it
should be possible to have a Skype II
connection with a passive client who can
see what you're doing
that is they can't write but he can read
and that encourages them to convert from
Skype feeding your product after they've
seen you know they can see how easy it
is for you but they can't write so then
they want to convert to your product
yeah so that could be a good some sort
of marketing strategy we haven't really
even begun to figure out exactly how
we're gonna go to people yeah
probably explain it to people when
everybody in undated for you with their
wish list so I lied one more to the wish
list for me which is Jupiter notebooks
yes so there I agree I think it would be
pretty cool to include some sort of code
support and yeah I will keep that in
mind yeah oh yeah you know and the
invite code is you will get one when you
put your email in and then if you so so
what we're hoping to do is as we sort of
slowly so we're hoping soon to be able
to release account so that you can save
what you're working on and we'd like to
invite people in groups so that you know
if a couple of people wanted to work on
it together we want to invite them off
the same time so that's what the invite
code is for
you